right now murray the only starter on the
floor for denver
plumley's pass deflected but goes it's
to murray puts it up puts it in
jamal murray now with 30 points murray
getting the basketball
look what i found but continues to make
big shots
and big plays for this nuggets team
little fade away
contested a 10-point denver lead
their largest of the game
leonard can't hit porter with a rebound
and the clippers could very well come
back and win this ball game but all year
we've been teased
but they've been inconsistent thinking
that they can turn it on when they want
to as lou williams misses the
easy one during the course of the year
point-blank range mark
beverly knocks it loose lou williams
just two of nine from the field
murray long three-pointer it's good
jamal murray from way downtown
it's a 15-point nugget lead time-out
clippers
murray denver nuggets here in game seven
[Applause]
long distance from murray
beverly drives against murray who gets
back defensively
now it's lou williams kicks it up top to
george just straight on three
in and out now the rebound jamal murray
patrick beverly with a steal and a
blocked shot two big defensive plays
leonard sidestep the runner's short he
thought he was fouled
and jokic can't foul
marcus morris three-pointer won't go
porter with a rebound
george looking to post up gets inside
his double team has to throw it back out
throws it away
gary harris drives down a lane layup
shot rattles around and drops through
leonard pulls up on milsat
shot no good on the follow is jamichael
green
leonard pulls up on milsat
shot no good on the follow is jamichael
greene
that was murray i would have let the
clock go to two minutes before i picked
it up
inside pass jokic flips it up and in
the clippers right now have no answers
for the nuggets
leonard for three beverly kicks it out
they've gotten a number of second shots
though george
way off it's the side of the backboard
and jokic with yet another rebound mike
malone calls timeout
they're in a great position harold goes
at jokic kicks it out george
corner three way off short and yolk it's
the rebound
murray trying to get it shot clock
winding down murray puts up a three
bang jamal murray from downtown
it's an 18-point lead
murray trying to get it shot clock
winding down murray puts up a three
bang jamal murray from downtown
it's an 18-point lead
36 for murray yokoch on the steal
ahead to grant
and the nuggets pouring it on time out
l.a
yokoch on the steal ahead to grant
and the nuggets pouring it on time out
la
a 20-point lead with 210 remaining
this is absolutely done an outstanding
job and deserves
an opportunity to lead his own team they
will all celebrate tonight jokic with
another pass as murray got fouled
that wasn't another pass mike that was
the pass
over the head come on he's toying with
the game now
and right on right in his hands he's
already got 13 assists
that would have been number 14 if
beverly didn't
6-0 in elimination games here in the
bubble much respect
for the coaching staffs
as the denver nuggets are going back to
the western conference finals
for the first time in 11 years